voilà
[Musique]
non
bonsoir il ya quelques
le panthéon il ya cette belle citation
qui dit aux grands hommes la patrie
reconnaissante
je me suis interrogé d'autant qu'il ya
des femmes maintenant dans le panthéon
mais fort heureusement encore assez mais
pourquoi privilégier seulement quelques
personnalités
pourquoi ne pas essayer de mobiliser
plus tôt de l'intelligence collective et
pourquoi essayer de servir uniquement la
patrie est pas la planète
est-ce qu'on pourrait donc changer cette
belle citation et dire à l'intelligence
collective la planète reconnaissante
pour arriver dans cette direction je
pense qu'on a besoin de créer des cadres
de liberté évolutif et fécond qui puisse
nous aider à construire une planète
apprenantes une société apprenantes
c'est à dire une société dans laquelle
quand quelqu'un a appris quelque chose
quelqu'un d'autre peut apprendre la même
chose facilement parce qu'on partage et
qu'on mutualisent nos connaissances un
des héros personnel mais aussi de la
nation puisqu'il est rentré au panthéon
c'est louis braille
vous connaissez peut-être le braille qui
permet aux aveugles de lire mais est ce
que vous savez que c'est un enfant qui
l'a inventé monsieur louis braille quand
il a inventé il avait 15 ans et il avait
commencé à travailler sur ce sujet à
partir de 12 ans il était devenu aveugle
quand il avait trois quatre ans et il
cherchait à lire mais il a pu inventer
lui même le braille et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que les adultes
voyant qu'ils s'occupaient de l'école
pour aveugles dans laquelle il était lui
ont interdit de le transmettre aux
autres parce qu'ils pensaient qu'ils
allaient les empêcher de lire avec les
méthodes traditionnelles que avait
inventé qui en l'occurrence ne marchait
pas pour la plupart des angles et donc
louis braille
malgré les adultes a su faire ça et à
l'internât il transmettait à ses petits
camarades cette méthode et il a fallu
que ses enfants se mobilisent pour
démontrer la qualité de l'apprentissage
qui était possible grâce aux barrages et
donc en l'occurrence il avait même
digitalisées l'information et on est au
19e siècle bien avant toutes les
technologies qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
évidemment louis braille a permis à bien
des aveugles de s'en sortir
à commencer par
une d'entre elles qui est très célèbre
qui est helen keller et helen keller non
seulement elle était aveugle mais elle
était aussi sourde et muette et il a
fallu une enseignante exceptionnelle
pour l'accompagner et lui permettre de
sortir de son isolement et donc il ya
depuis toujours de nouvelles manières
d'apprendre une nouvelle manière de
transmettre qui sont inventés et
louis-braille helen keller et son
enseignante font partie des héros qui
ont su inventer de nouvelles manières
dès cette époque là un autre point
intéressant sur helen keller c'est que
le jour où les cendres de louis braille
sont rentrés au panthéon
helen keller était là et elle a fait un
beau discours en sorbonne où elle disait
que la seule chose qui soit pire que de
ne pas voir c'est de ne pas avoir de
vision alors on a tous des limitations
dans notre vision et il ya une belle
légende indienne qui s'appelle la
légende de l'éléphant et des six aveugle
et vous voyez chacun de ces aveugles
représenté ici est celui qui touche la
trompe est persuadé que c'est un serpent
celui qui touche l'oreille que c'est un
tapis celui qui touche le corps que
c'est un mur et ils sont incapables de
se mettre d'accord parce qu'ils sont
tous persuadés d'avoir raison et tous
persuadés que les autres ont tort et il
faut que quelqu'un passe à côté qui leur
disent que ils ont tous une partie de la
réalité qu'ils ont été capables de
percevoir mais sont pas forcément la
bonne interprétation et s'ils étaient
capables de mutualiser leurs
connaissances respectives
alors peut-être qu'il pourrait arriver à
avancer et à mieux comprendre et à
mobiliser leur intelligence collective
alors je pense qu'on a besoin
d'apprendre à apprendre en tant
qu'individu mais aussi en tant que
collectif ça veut dire qu'on a besoin de
devenir plus réflexif on a besoin de
réfléchir sur ce que c'est qu'à prendre
sur ce que c'est qu'à prendre
individuellement mais aussi avec
d'autres et grâce à d'autres
est-ce qu'on peut s'organiser pour faire
en sorte que à chaque fois qu'on apprend
quelqu'un d'autre puisse apprendre plus
facilement est ce qu'on peut apprendre
tout au long de sa vie est-ce que cet
apprentissage peut s'adosser sur la
recherche et sur les progrès des
connaissances
je pense qu'on a
d'intégrer toujours plus de regards la
plupart des gens qui pensent le système
éducatif sont des adultes et c'est bien
dommage je pense qu'on a besoin
d'interroger les enfants je me félicite
que j'en ai au moins quelques-uns dans
la salle 95% des jeunes à qui on demande
si le système éducatif devrait changer
disent oui mais trop rarement leur
demande ce qu'ils voudraient on change
dans ce système éducatif et donc on fait
des réformes
heureusement mais malheureusement pas
toujours dans la bonne direction et pas
toujours aussi importante que ce qu'il
faudrait pour s'adapter à un monde qui a
beaucoup changé alors une des choses que
j'ai apprises par la recherche grâce à
alison gopnik est une chercheuse à
berkeley c'est que nous sommes tous nés
chercheurs et donc nous sommes tous
capables de questionner le monde de
faire des observations le faire des
expériences d'analyser les données et de
raconter ce qu'on a trouvé et d'inviter
d'autres à reproduire ce qu'on a fait
comme vous le voyez avec ce petit bébé
qu'il leur présente alors ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que les enfants sont
des petits chercheurs et les chercheurs
de grands enfants
en tant que chercheur j'assume ce besoin
parce que c'est vrai que le pic de
curiosité en général il est à 4 ans donc
si on continue à se questionner toute sa
vie je pense que c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel mais ce n'est pas forcément
quelque chose qui est nécessairement
recommandé alors on a monté un programme
qui s'appelle les savanturiers qui
invite les enfants à le faire des
expériences comme vous pouvez le voir
avec ces jeunes filles ou c'est comme
vous pouvez le voir aussi ses enfants
vont dans des conférences et présentent
leurs travaux exactement comme le font
les chercheurs et donc ce projet d
savanturiers est né dans la classe que
vous voyez en haut à gauche de l'image
la classe dans gens sourds dans une zone
d'éducation prioritaire
il ya quelques années maintenant il ya
cinq ans aujourd'hui plus de 50000
personnes enfants et adultes ont été
impliqués dans les programmes
d'éducation par la recherche est ce
qu'on fait c'est que l'on parle
questionnement de l'enfant et on essaie
de transformer en un questionnement
scientifique en invitant les enfants à
travailler avec des mentors chercheurs
qui accompagne le questionnement des ans
et donc on a essayé de créer une école
apprenantes c'est à dire une école ou
quand un enfant a appris quelque chose
un autre enfant voir après
facilement parce qu'ils coopèrent plus
tôt de leur interdire de copier on les
invite à coopérer et en fait cette
capacité de créer une école d'apprenants
plein d'autres gens ont pu l'inventer à
leur manière au 19e siècle
ça existait déjà et la vidéo vous voyez
qui est la photo qui est un extrait de
cnn avec le plus jeune principal d'école
c'est un jeune homme qui avait 15 ans
sur la photo que vous voyez mais quand
il a eu huit ans il a créé son école
ils avaient la chance que ses parents
puissent payer pour l'envoyer à l'école
mais ses petits camarades n'avaient pas
cette chance
donc quand il est rentré de l'école il a
commencé à leur raconter ce qu'ils
avaient appris
et puis de jour en jour il a continué
leur apprendre et y en avait toujours
plus au début c'était que quatre au
moment où cette photo a été prise il y
avait mille enfants dans l'école qu'il
avait créé et ça moi je suis très
impressionné par ce genre de choses
un autre exemple d'école que je trouve
absolument remarquable qui d'ailleurs a
eu prix de la fondation légaux comme
étant la meilleure école du monde se
trouve être en haïti donc ce n'est pas
une école de californie ou de finlande
où de jeunes saison c'est en haïti c'est
un ami qui la dirige
guy étienne et cet enfant que vous voyez
utilise des matériaux recyclés pour
créer des robots et guy etienne a
demandé à ses enfants qu'elle était le
caractérise de ce robot est une des
caractéristiques c'est qu'il avait un
numéro d'identification et qui etienne
lui a dit mais pourquoi est ce qu'il a
un numéro et l'enfant lui a répondu ben
j'ai programmé ce robot pour ce soit
gentil mais en fait je ne suis pas
certain de la manière dont je les
programmer et si un jour il faisait
quelque chose que je n'avais pas
souhaité alors grâce au numéro on pourra
le retrouver
un autre exemple formidable a été créée
par kieran que vous voyez au centre de
cette photo et vous voyez plein
d'enfants avec aykan le virus qu'elle a
essayé de leur inoculer c'est le virus
de jeu peu parce qu'on peut tous faire
autrement et ce virus kieran la propager
aujourd'hui à des millions d'enfants
dans le monde
en france ce programme a été intégrée
par l'association syllabe qui porte le
projet bâti sur de possibles et s'est
basé sur ces quatre idées simples qui
sont indiqués la première s'est
identifié un problème pour lesquels les
enfants se sentent concernés la deuxième
cd invite à imaginer une solution
la troisième c'est des invités à mettre
en oeuvre cette solution est la
quatrième c'est de raconter leur
histoire
c'est super simple ça marche super bien
il ya des millions d'enfants qui ont
contribué à changer leur environnement
grâce à ce virus
aïe cannes en fait on peut le faire
beaucoup plus largement les nations
unies ont défini les dix sept grandes
priorités de la planète
on appelle les objectifs de le mans
durable le quatrième c'est l'éducation
donc on a beaucoup parlé aujourd'hui
mais le premier c'est la pauvreté
le troisième c'est la santé il ya le
climat la biodiversité les problèmes de
genre
tous les grands problèmes sont là et
bien en fait avec des programmes comme
celui que je viens d indiquer on peut
inviter les enfants à comprendre ces
grands défis et à essayer de les
surmonter et de contribuer et donc
plutôt de les mettre en compétition sur
les savoirs d'hier on peut les invités à
coopérer pour créer les solutions de
demain et on peut le faire avec des
enfants on peut le faire à tous les
niveaux on peut le faire dans des
universités on peut inviter des
étudiants à s'intéresser à ces grands
défis à comprendre leur complexité et à
prototyper des solutions on a été amené
à le faire en collaboration avec de
grandes universités comme harvard
sciences po les meilleures universités
chinoises ou d'autres partenaires en
travers la planète
donc en fait partout chacun d'entre nous
peut contribuer à identifier des
problèmes et à chercher les solutions
collectivement et éventuellement être
reconnu pour ce que l'on aura fait
et on a aussi besoin de le faire à tous
les âges de la vie
on vient de nous annoncer que 10 à 50%
des métiers allait disparaître ou se
transformer profondément parce que
l'informatique
l'intelligence artificielle l'art
gothique vont transformer en profondeur
les manières de travailler
alors comment est ce qu'on va faire
c'est pas la première révolution
la première révolution industrielle par
exemple à transformer profondément les
métiers mais ça s'est passé assez
lentement et donc ce qui s'est passé
depuis le 19e siècle
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ce
graphique c'est que chaque année chaque
décennie pardon on a ajouté une année de
formation en moyenne mais là comme les
changements sont toujours plus rapide il
faudrait rajouter peut-être un an chaque
année évidemment on pourra pas mais
l'autre manière de le faire c'est de
continuer à prendre tout le long de sa
vie et d'apprendre en travaillant
d'apprendre en coopérant d'apprendre en
échangeant une des propositions qu'on
est en train d'essayer de faire pour
faire ça c'est de créer des labos des
métiers de demain
si les métiers de demain n'existe pas
encore peut-être qu'il faut les inventer
et comme personne ne les connaît eh bien
peut-être qu'il faut qu'on les co
invente en puisque chacun d'entre nous a
peut-être un bond de solutions pro
moment pas la solution mais si on
mutualisent les éléments de solution
on a chacun en nous alors on va pouvoir
essayer de faire des choses
collectivement qu'on serait passé recel
et donc je pense qu'on a besoin de créer
des collectifs ouvert qui soient à la
recherche de sa nouvelle solution un
petit peu comme dans les fables que vous
connaissez probablement en fait je pense
qu'on a besoin de co construire tous
ensemble nous c était de la connaissance
et de la reconnaissance
donc on a besoin de reconnaître les
nouvelles manières d'apprendre les
nouvelles manières de créer de la
connaissance des nouvelles manières de
s'approprier cette connaissance
évidemment les diplômes et les brevets
et ce genre de choses sont la manière
dont on a reconnu la connaissance
jusqu'à maintenant mais aujourd'hui il
ya bien d'autres manières de le faire
sur internet il ya bien d'autres formes
de connaissance et de reconnaissance qui
circulent aujourd'hui une des choses que
l'on est en train de proposer
gouvernement c'est de créer des carnets
d'apprenants pour conques arctique
cartographie tout au long de notre vie
nos explorations nos apprentissages
ça nous aide à nous orienter ça nous
aide à faire des rencontres ça nous aide
à aller toujours plus loin
et de même que vous avez un carnet de
santé vous pouvez avoir un carnet de
l'apprenant qui vous permet de garder
pour vous ce qui est le plus pertinent
pour chacun d'entre nous et je pense que
ça peut permettre de repenser des
concepts qui sont aussi vieux que les
grecs 1 vous connaissez connaît sois toi
même qui était écrit au temple de
delphes et s'inspirer d'autres
civilisations en l'occurrence le japon
l'ikigami pour les japonais c'est le
sens de la vie comment est ce qu'on
trouve son équivalent quand on est
japonais eh bien on se pose en quatre
questions qu'est ce qu'on aime
qu'est ce qu'on sait faire de quoi le
monde a besoin
ou est-ce que je peux trouver les
ressources pour avancer et si vous savez
travailler sur ces intersections vous
allez pouvoir trouver votre passion
votre vocation votre profession est
votre mission
et si vous savez travailler vraiment au
coeur de tout ça vous arriverez à
trouver quelque chose qui vous
correspond et que vous pouvez partager
pour le faire en tant qu'individu point
invité en tant que parents vos enfants à
le faire pourrait le faire en tant que
collectif une école comme celle ci peut
s'interroger sur quelle libéré de son de
l'école une organisation toute
organisation humaine que seul interrogé
là-dessus
le pays pourrait s'interroger la planète
même pour s interroger sur qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un liquide gagne je pense que
face aux grands défis comme le climat on
a su créer le groupe international
d'études sur le climat le giec mais il
ya d'autres défis le défi de
l'intelligence artificielle est
certainement un autre défi si les
machines ça va prendre
comment est ce que nous on peut
apprendre collectivement si pour faire
face aux enjeux du climat on a su
rassembler les meilleurs chercheurs de
la planète pour travailler sur le sujet
si on a su mobiliser les opinions
publiques du monde
pourquoi ne pas faire la même chose sur
les nouvelles manières d'apprendre
donc si on doit construire une planète
apprenantes est ce qu'on ne peut pas
inviter tous les citoyens
tous les chercheurs à mutualiser leurs
efforts pour essayer de relever ce défi
une des manières de le faire je vous ai
dit qu'on est tous les chercheurs c'est
de tous contribué à cette recherche
alors ya un concept qui existe
aujourd'hui qu'on appelle les sciences
citoyennes ou les sciences
participatives dans lesquelles tous les
citoyens sont invités à partager et à
contribuer au progrès de la recherche
donc ça existe dans le domaine de la
biodiversité vous pouvez vous promener
votre téléphone
photographier les petites fleurs et les
petits oiseaux les géolocaliser dans le
temps et dans l'espace et contribuer à
cartographier la manière dont la
biodiversité évolue en temps réel tous
ensemble pour faire la même chose sur
votre santé
si vous êtes impatients et vous voulez
contribuer à faire avancer plus vite la
recherche biomédicale et donc vous êtes
doublement un patient d'un patient en
patient si vous avez compris ce que je
veux dire et bien vous pouvez contribuer
à faire accélérer la recherche
si on veut faire progresser la recherche
sur la prendre personne ne sait
exactement ce que c'est qu'à prendre
pour vous si ce n'est vous même et donc
on peut interroger chacun d'entre nous
et on peut tous contribué à faire une
science participative de qu'est-ce que
c'est qu'à prendre aujourd'hui ces
problèmes en différents en partie au
moins pour chacun d'entre nous on aime
certains modes d'apprentissage plus que
d'autres mais ça si on pouvait
contribuer tous à sétif à ce sujet on
irait probablement beaucoup plus vite
parce qu on pourrait mutualiser nos
apprentissages
ça suppose de revenir à ce que ces mêmes
que la connaissance
pour aristote il ya bien longtemps déjà
il y avait trois formes de connaissances
est pisté mais qui est la connaissance
du monde qui a donné la science
l'épistémologie technique et comment
est-ce qu'on agit sur le monde qui a
donné la technologie et vous voyez bien
que la science et la technologie ont
beaucoup progressé depuis l'époque
d'aristote
le troisième pilier de la connaissance
pour lui c'est la prenait 6 l'un prenait
6 beaucoup de gens ont oublié ce que
c'était
c'est l'éthique de l'action et c'est
dommage de ce qu'on a fait progresser
beaucoup la science et la technologie et
peu l'éthique et la réflexion collective
sur ce qu'il serait utile de faire donc
je pense qu'on a besoin de faire
progresser nos intelligences
individuelles et collectives au moins
autant que les machines et leur
intelligence vont progresser aujourd'hui
on investit des milliards sur
l'intelligence artificielle
je pense qu'on a aussi besoin d'investir
sur le développement de nos
intelligences et nos intelligences sont
plurielles et nos intelligences
rationnelle nos intelligences et
émotionnel de intelligence relationnelle
et jean pax pour mener ce cette
transformation s'est en grande partie un
changement culturel auquel je en train
de vous appeler une manière de
célébrez d'autres manières d'apprendre
c'est peut-être de faire une fête de la
prendre
une fête de la prendre ça peut paraître
un peu étrange mais ça existe dans plein
d'endroits
il ya des entreprises par exemple qui se
célèbre ce qu'on apprend dans son
entreprise il ya des écoles qui s'élève
ce qu'on apprend dans une école il ya
des pays entiers qui célèbre à l'échelle
du pays
ce que l'on apprend donc si on
s'emparait de ça vous connaissez tous la
fête de la musique par exemple
et bien quand on célèbre la musique on
célèbre ce que l'on a appris en musique
est ce qu'on a envie de partager avec
les autres et bien une fête de la
prendre c'est la même chose
qu'est ce que vous avez appris depuis un
an qui est pertinent pour vous et qu'est
ce que vous auriez envie de partager
avec d'autres
et si vous célébriez vos propre
apprentissage vous pourriez également
célébrés ce qui vous ont permis
d'apprendre ça peut être votre enfant
qui vous a aidé à apprendre quelque
chose sur ce que c'est qu'être un enfant
ça peut être votre grand-mère qui vous a
appris la dernière recette qu'elle avait
envie de vous transmettre ça peut être
un enseignant qui vous a transmis
quelque chose de pertinent ça peut être
un ami vous l'avoir appris à réparer une
mobylette et on est très fiers vous
pouvez a appris à jouer et à passer un
cap qui voulaient qui est important pour
vous et en est très fière et donc
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait célébrer
ses mille et une manières d'apprendre
c'est ça le défi à mon avis et si on
s'est célébré ses mille et une manières
d'apprendre si on sait les partager on
peut réfléchir non seulement à ce que
l'on a appris mais ce que l'on
souhaiterait à prendre en tant
qu'individu ou en tant que collectif et
si vous souhaitez apprendre de nouvelles
choses
il est bien possible qu'un autre dans
cette salle où dans votre quartier et a
pris la même chose et serait ravi de
vous l'apprendre à son tour est donc
plutôt que de mettre les gens en
compétition sur les savoirs d'hier on
peut les invités à coopérer pour
apprendre les uns des autres et pour
construire le monde de demain
merci
[Applaudissements]